is there a reason why god is associated
with becoming rather than being or
rather than a combination of both
becoming and being
well
there are as many ideas of god as there
are you know traditions in the world and
probably as many as there are people
so
ideas about god
can be very different
but
i have
noted a very interesting strain
in the mythologies and
anthropologies of peoples
around the world from
china and india from
um
[Music]
from the circumpolar regions from the
native american peoples and so on that
speak
of
a world that is becoming not just made
but is constantly coming into being
and i think that ultimately
you can bring together the idea of a god
that is
eternally and a god that is coming into
being but if i had to put my money on
one or the other it would be the coming
into being it seems to me that that is
utterly primary and interestingly people
like paulie and heisenberg and
and uh uh scherdinger and so forth in
the 20th century
thought similarly that becoming was more
important than being david bohm said
that as well
and i think neil's poor
okay this reminds me of another line
from your book and it could be you said
the mind or the brain i don't i don't
remember which one which we can talk
about what's the difference between the
mind and the brain but regardless you
said either the mind or the brain it's
not correct to think of it as the the
brain slash mind is grappling with the
world but instead it's bringing the
world about
okay now to some that conflates the
objective world with the
phenomenological one so i'm wondering
can you explain what you mean when you
say it brings the world about
well i may not be able to explain it
very well in language because i think
our language is not very well suited to
describing
reality it's very well suited to
describing everyday things like getting
lunch
and uh
building a wall but when it comes to
actually understanding what we're
dealing with we don't necessarily have
the words for it
and you know boar himself said there is
no way we can talk about physics
eventually except in the language of
poetry and he said the same thing is
true
of um philosophy and and of
the talking about the divine or whatever
it is so
yes
what i've struggled with very much is
not collapsing into one or other of two
major areas of our age
one is to say quite simply it's all made
up by us so it's like we're sitting in a
little um cinema inside our heads you
know sitting on the sofa little
homunculus watching the scene but we
have no contact with the world of
anything else out there and the other is
that you know just the world is out
there and it's just a matter of going
out measuring it photographing it and
you've got it so you know in one case
you've got very simplistic materialism
and in the other you've got very
simplistic idealism and i don't think
that either of these positions
gets us very far
i think the important thing is to see
these bridges because as i say
everything is actually connected and
it's through the connection that they
come into being
so let me
say that again because it's something
that again as a physicist you will
understand you probably know david
merman the physicist he says
relations are prior to relata now i was
delighted when i heard that because i
have been working on that basis for most
of my adult life and that sounds
nonsense to most people how can
relations exist before there are things
that relate
but actually the things only become what
they are in the process of the
relationship
indeed we only are what we are as human
beings in the process of the many
relationships we have with other people
and with the world at large
and there's an
image in
the vedic
tradition which i like very much of
indra's net
and indra's net is a cosmic
uh net that covers the whole
world
and
in it at every place where the threads
cross there was a little jewel and in
this jewel it reflected all the other
jewels and the whole of the net so it's
like a hologram in a way but what is
fabulous about it is that
they point out that the threads the
connections exist before any of the
points that make a net the things that
make it a net are the crossings that's
what we see but they just stand forward
after
interesting uh the relations have done
what they are so i think it's a good
image because i think we tend to focus
on certain things that stand forward to
us
in the world immediately and neglect the
background out of which they emerge and
from which they're never separate and
this is a very basic neuropsychological
distinction between the left and right
hemisphere which you can demonstrate in
the lab any day the left hemisphere sees
a single thing of interest that is
foregrounded and it ignores the rest
whereas the right hemisphere sees the
whole scene with whatever it is embedded
in it